all right guys before this gets started
i just wanted to let you know so this is
kind of the group of youtubers that one
guy recruited me into
so it's just kind of a tournament for
fun and this guy i'll show you tell you
all the rules so just sit back relax and
enjoy
hey guys welcome to the first ever
crafty bomber tournament here we have
all of these people we got let's see
let's have we got noah necro mouse mad
luigi prestige uh crazy dark flame dj
brian alpha wolf leo uh blizzard two
dimensions we got james waldo and jake
and uh and myself and uh we're going to
be splitting up into four teams over the
course of these we're gonna play four
games
and uh the winner whoever wins the most
games will be the winner and uh all that
good stuff so we're gonna split up the
calls and go into our games and uh we
will see you guys in a minute
yo guys what's up this is prestige and
as stryker said we're in a crafty obama
tournament
so here you go yeah it just paid it's
kind of like if you've ever played
bomberman it's basically like an edited
minecraft version of that
well my internet is [ __ ] bricks
right now
that's good
oh check that out so when i drop one of
my tnts i can go into this mode and i
can see all the other people doing stuff
so
yeah awesome all right all right so
welcome back guys mousecraft and today
i'm here with
what do you got not the dimensions uh
mad luigi
uh we got uh necroflame and uh
no it has oh i got a virus yes
oh he has a virus who viruses are the
most annoying thing ever
so right now my internet is taking a
giant dump and i don't know what's going
on with it but i have a virus what's
that a virus means oh there's a virus i
didn't pick it up though uh
virus makes you um
have
super limited eyesight basically yeah it
sucks dude it's too good you could
infect people with it yeah if you punch
them with your fists so guys watch it
no you can it's a power up that you can
pick up with the kind of reverse power
up you can pick it up or get infected
but when someone touches
uh for everybody watching my video right
that right there is a virus and i'm not
going to pick that up because i don't
want to
have terrible eyesight
yeah
so basically the whole goal the whole
goal is just like uh be the last one
standing um and once you get power-ups
along with it to help you out trap
people in corners to kill them and so on
so it's pretty fun tournament yeah
when you're interested in a giant that's
true
yeah everything's delayed for me it's so
annoying with the oh okay can't place
tnt
can't place tnt right same here oh
yes what i see myself guys i see myself
like i'm in third person mode but i'm
not oh i got infected
oh what the heck
oh man the server is so [ __ ] laggy
what the heck i honestly don't
understand
and and i have a virus okay so everyone
watching this is really like everyone
watching this killed mouse i apologize
for um this isn't what this is the first
time it's ever happened to me this is
not the normal
bomby crafter
crafter bomby
oh my gosh oh my gosh this is the best
game ever best game ever
oh
small craft quit oh i got killed oh that
fixed it thank you but i'm experiencing
lag now oh that's nice
oh i still see my body
no no sorry you just got rid of the
virus i still can't do anything
oh oh okay well
guys yeah this you can hear the sky
skype chat going all weird
uh a skype oh
yeah i'm pretty sure minecraft was the
head of the call
so i'm just gonna call everyone back
that should hurt
can i end it on him
and these people are busy nice all right
so basically i lost this match because i
can't to help is it fixed
nope it's not fixed
oh
i'm kicking ass right now guys hello
i am kicking ass right now i'm killing
everyone literally
i can't play so good job killing me
oh my god hey guys
uh what what the heck
i think mouse is still
reviving his
yeah oh he's back so i killed myself no
i don't know how i broke this game
so i it's broken forever okay
all right well i lost that round guys uh
i'll talk to you next round not the
people my game
people in the chat hopefully next round
not the chat the video hopefully the
next game actually is good and yeah see
you then peace and we are back guys and
i'm here with my luigi um
jake the snake
and
uh
crazy horse sorry yeah crazy yo what's
up guys ice floor might be a little
interesting hopefully awesome you're
gonna be able to sprint jump so fast
you're gonna just be going
you can't jump
you can't jump but no you can do that
thing like where the when there's a
block on top of you and you gotta
have spacebar and go a million miles oh
you can
oh
all right well it looks like the game's
working this time guys everyone watching
my video so that that's a plus from last
game
i got a bomb
nice
i see someone is making their way
towards me
oh oh crap crap oh crap oh crap no no no
no yes there that's what i'm talking
about oh you're so lucky oh my god
yeah
oh mate i wish i could place another
bomb
oh there we go
yeah i think i'm crashing it yeah crap
oh that's good
oh
well i'll oscar you
it's for you screw you get fourth place
why didn't you mind him at all oh my god
really really again
no no no
ah screw this
yourself oh my gosh
i'm too good at this game
no no no no no no no
oh my gosh
oh god
where did you where are you
i'm nowhere near
i will never break your defense oh you
might want to look behind you
there might be a person behind you just
maybe
you might be a person right in front of
you
oh you're behind me actually
ah nope no that's not gonna work it's
gonna work i don't know did you see the
placement back there i can't see
ah screw this
oh you infected me
oh my god
get home yeah take take this stupid
disease
i didn't get it what no no he did
my job jake's disease ridden
oh no no no screw you
yeah take your disease no no
ah
oh crap no oh
no
i'll scream scream
oh dang it dang it
oh my freaking yes
oh one bomb delay oh
dang
yep yeah yeah yep wait i can't actually
survive this no dang it oh now you're
dead now you're dead no no i'm getting
the good stuff oh screw
ah
oh my gosh all right well that was
another third place for me hope you guys
enjoyed that round be back at you with
the next round later peace out
all right guys hope you enjoyed this
first two rounds of the tournament the
next two rounds i did do uh better so be
on the lookout for that i'll post that
video sometime in the future and yeah
peace out guys
wow oh my god